[Applaudissements]
ce soir c'est de ce papillon aux ailes
transparentes dont je viens vous parler
je les filme et cet été pendant une
mission de terrain en amérique du sud
on est parti les observer peut-être me
direz vous c'est une drôle d'idée de
traverser la moitié du globe pour une
raison pareil mais si je viens partager
ce projet avec vous c'est que je pense
qu'il contient quelques données
essentielles sur notre rapport au vivant
alors installez vous bien au fond de
votre siège pour un voyage aux
perceptions élargie sur les ailes de ces
papillons transparent c'est vrai la
question légitime comment est-ce qu'on
en vient à travailler sur un sujet aussi
spécifique pour ma part je pense que ça
a été un joyeux mélange de curiosité
beaucoup de hasards aussi qui a commencé
il ya trois ans en école d'ingénieur pas
très loin d'ici
la première année à vrai dire c'était
d'abord une césure consacré à la musique
au violoncelle juste pour travailler
papillon de gabriel fauré évidemment et
ensuite une première année d'école et
puis le redoublement de cette première
année alors c'est vrai le parcours a été
un peu semé d'embûches mais je pense que
c'est quand on commence à se demander
vraiment pourquoi on est là qu'on a
envie de donner du sens à ce qu'on fait
bon le lien avec les papillons celle
optique que j'ai étudié dans cette école
alors l'optique c'est pas forcément
celle des lunettes de vue mais il faut
la voir de façon plus générale comme la
physique de la lumière de son
interaction avec la matière c'est dans
ce domaine que j'ai été d'abord
stagiaire puis apprenti dans un
laboratoire du muséum d'histoire
naturelle qui s'appelle le centre de
recherche sur la conservation des
collections et dans ce cadre il ya une
collaboration formidable entre des
chercheuse en biologie et physique du
muséum qui m'a embarqué dans ce projet
sur les papillons transparent ou mes
compétences en optique devait permettre
de comprendre caractériser les messages
visuels porté par ces membranes d'elle
transparente
alors j'ai bien dit message visuel d'une
surface transparente ça peut paraître un
peu paradoxal de prime abord mais en
fait non vous voyez bien une vitre vous
pourrez pas passer votre main au travers
alors une aile de papillon non plus même
si c'est pas recommandé alors comment
est ce qu'on fait alors de quoi est ce
qu'elle est faite cette transparence et
comment on peut la caractériser bon ça
c'est en se servant des outils de figue
de pointe dont on dispose de
laboratoires qu'on va commencer cet
itinéraire ados d'aile de papillon
dans un premier temps l'idée ça va être
d'en explorer la surface et de s'en
rapprocher au plus
et pour avoir le relief et les aspérités
pour la petite histoire
peut-être que vous savez que le nom
savant des papillons ces lépidoptères en
latin ça signifie elle à écailles parce
qu'en fait si jamais vous les touchez il
ya une poudre qui se dépose sur vos
doigts qui est en fait loin d'être
anodine puisque cette poudre ce sont des
milliers des cayes que vous avez en fait
arracher de la surface et ce sont elles
qui d'habitude formes et motifs colorés
qu'on leur connaît bon alors vous allez
me dire oui mais su qu'on a vu là il est
transparent d'accord justement on s'est
dit c'est cette membrane elle existe
elle est bien faite de quelque chose et
c'est là qu'on a commencé à se demander
comment on allait pouvoir les regarder
alors première étape on a été au centre
de recherche sur la conservation des
collections on a une loupe binoculaire
binoculaire pardon c'est en fait juste
une grosse loupe sous laquelle on a mis
le papillon la voilà donc cette aile de
papillon on l'a observé à la loupe
ici il ya un grossissement pas encore
énorme on va jusqu'à poisson est en fait
ben voilà le renoncer lépidoptères qui
veut dire elle à écaillon s'attendaient
peut-être à retrouver des écailles dans
sa surface transparente mais on a
découvert une espèce de forêt de poils
bon pourquoi pas on s'est dit que quand
même ça semblait se décliner selon les
espèces donc ça valait vraiment le coup
d'aller voir d'un peu plus près d'accord
dans ce cas on s'est rendu à l'institut
de physique du globe à paris voir
stéphane bernstein qui est spécialiste
du microscope électronique à balayage en
fait le microscope électronique à
balayage michael son nom barbare c'est
juste un microscope qui permet d'imagés
une surface de façon très précise et
très heureux de lui grâce à un faisceau
d'électrons s'est rendu là bas et on a
retrouvé cette forêt de poil à la
surface de la membrane qu'on voit ici
horizontalement puis en naviguant un peu
plus loin ou bien en allant chez
d'autres espèces
cette fois on a retrouvé les écailles
qui a dans le nom de lépidoptères avec
des poils un peu hybride enfin ça se
déclinait et l'appareil il est tellement
puissant qu'en fait on peut zoomer
jusqu'à la zone d'insertion d'une de ses
écailles en gros c'est encore un peu on
dirait que c'est une immense feuille en
fait non c'est une écaille sur la
membrane et on voit que cette surface
donc juste cette surface transparente
n'est pas du tout plane elle est
constituée de motifs irrégulier et
bosselée et que si on lit m'avait les
images parrot dessus serre sur certaines
espèces on observe même une mosaïque
étonnamment belmont je trouve de ces
nanostructures bosselé alors pour se
rendre compte puisque c'est pas très
évident de réaliser qu est ce que
signifient ces grossissement si on est
tirés
si on est tirés cette aile de papillon
sur la largeur de la france c'est-à-dire
un bon strasbourg brest qu'on met 10
heures en voiture à faire quand ça roule
et bien une seule de ces anneaux
structure la forêt précisément la taille
de ce tapis voilà tout ça relève de
l'infant infiniment petit c'est
difficilement concevable mais n'empêche
que ça existe c'est bien pour ça que la
transparence n'est pas du vide et qu'en
plus elle est infiniment complexe bon
certes on a vu tout ça existait mais
qu'est ce que à quoi ça peut bien servir
si c'est là sur cl aujourd'hui c'est
bien qu'il ya une raison alors là on
arrive dans la deuxième étape de notre
voyage exploratoire sur ses ailes de
papillon et il s'agit maintenant de
comprendre à quoi servent toutes ces
structures qui en fait positionne à
elles toutes accumulées l'effet visuel
global de l'ale c'est à dire ce qu'on
voit quand on le regarde avec nos yeux
alors par exemple la mosaïque de nos
structures pour pour prendre quelque
chose que nous opticiens on connaît ce
sont en fait les motifs assez
caractéristique des surfaces antireflet
et en fait ça en termes un peu
finalistes ça permet aux papillons bas
de ne pas scintillé dans l'air au
moindre battement d'aile et donc de ne
pas passer pour une prof faciles pour
leurs prédateurs
les oiseaux d'ailleurs si ça les
prédateurs des papilles mais ont en
effet il faut bien se dire que ce qui
nous intéresse ici c'est bien l'oeil du
prédateur et leur dû et l'oeil du
papillon parce que nos yeux de
scientifiques ils sont conditionnés par
leur vision c'est à dire par les
photorécepteurs présents sur notre
rétine or les papillons n'ont pas les
mêmes il en nous même certains qui leur
permet d'accéder à l'est des longueurs
d'onde que nous ne voyons pas être
humain avec nos yeux en les regardant
dans la forêt pour ça il était donc
nécessaire de s'équiper d'un autre type
de caméra
si cette fois ci c'est une caméra ultra
violet qui permet donc de voir ses
rayons qui nous brûle la politesse sur
la plage et donc voilà l arrivée ya pas
longtemps et je suis en train de les
saigner donc la lampe fonctionne et on
voit bien que on arrive à vérifier sens
et brosser les dents correctement le
matin de façon disons plus scientifique
notre hypothèse serait avec cette caméra
de réussir à images et des surfaces
dans les zones transparente qui ne
soient pas très homogène faisaient trop
émotif quelque chose en tout cas qui
nous permettent de comprendre notamment
comment les papillons se reconnaissent
et comment ils ne se trompent pas de
partenaires sexuels
ce qui est le risque d'une descendance
terrils et puis plus de descendance du
tout en fait
on arrive maintenant un stade de cet
itinéraire où on commence à comprendre
quels types de ce qu'une structure font
ça et elle de quoi elle est constituée
et comment l'observer alors c'est vrai
je vous ai pas encore parlé d'
iridescence polarisation d'extraction de
l'adn de séquençage de charline de tati
sur air de dissection de chrysalide ou
encore de test de thermorégulation mais
c'est pas très grave
ce sera une autre fois tu me promet il
ya une chose cependant il faut vraiment
mentionné quand on parle d'optique et on
veut pas faire abstraction de ça c'est
ce que sous-entend l'interaction lumière
matière alors la matière oui on l'a
utilisé c'est elle que depuis le début
donc comment qu'on regarde sous toutes
ses coutures depuis les forêts des cayes
au microscope électronique jusqu'à la
vision uv mais en revanche la lumière
elle c'est celle qui touche ses écailles
et ces membranes d'aile de papillon dans
la vraie vie c'est à dire en amérique du
sud dans la forêt et sans elle il manque
la moi c'est l'information en tant que
scientifique
alors il est temps pour ce que j'ai
perdu avec la physique d'enfiler une
paire de bottes et de me suivre sur le
terrain en amérique du sud
c'est là que je suis parti cet été en
mission de terrain avec une équipe de
chercheuse du muséum d'histoire
naturelle donc avec diverses questions
de physique et de biologie en tête donc
on s'est rendu dans des zones en
équateur et au pérou
ce qu'ils sont en fait à la limite entre
la cordillère des andes et la forêt
amazonienne et ce sont des endroits
vraiment très réputés pour leur
diversité d'espèces puisque se
rencontrent les espèces qui fut
d'habitude à basse altitude décèle un
peu plus haut donc on a commencé d'abord
en équateur à 1000 mètres d'altitude
dans la station biologique de gannat
yacou nous c'est un endroit assez
extraordinaire à 1000 mètres d'altitude
donc dans paint mis en pleine forêt
tropicale et c'est un lieu de rencontres
entre des chercheurs puisque on est
vraiment au milieu du terrain
et puis il ya des machettes à proximité
donc on peut faire un peu ce que nos
recherches implique qu'on fait comme
démarche
dans la forêt donc nous par exemple
complet pour les papiers en transparent
mais aussi un couple de chercheurs qui
travaillent sur des feuilles faut
seulement là-bas et puis un troisième
qui ça c'est les araignées au
brumisateur
enfin vraiment un univers complètement
atypique que jamais jamais j'aurais
pensé découvrir avant d'y mettre les
pieds alors en parlant de pieds
je crois que les bottes en caoutchouc
c'est le meilleur investissement de tout
ce voyage puisque en effet dans ces
forêts il fait aussi humide que froid et
oui je pense que toute l'équipe on a
simultanément en fils et tous les
t-shirts notre valise pour essayer de
survivre au froid qu'on vivait là-bas
c'est le genre de choses qu'on apprend
sur le terrain sens y être vraiment
attendu avant comme le fait de ranger
ses bottes la tête en bas parce que
sinon le lendemain on trouve des
grenouilles à l'intérieur voilà donc on
en rigolait bien tout ça le soir à la
chandelle quand parfois dans
l'électricité arrivait plus à la station
parce que un glissement de terrain avait
emporté un poteau électrique
plus concrètement quand même ma mission
là-bas c'était de faire une étude
physique de la lumière ambiante
c'est à dire que je devais me rendre
dans tous les micro habitats dans
lesquelles a vite les papillons dans la
forêt est caractérisée physiquement
cette lumière avec des outils objectifs
du coup à la randonnée dans les bois et
parfois elle voilà jusqu'à 20 mètres de
hauteur dans la canopée puisque ça fait
partie des endroits où on trouve ces
pavillons transparent et avec moi dans
tous et dans tous ces endroits là j'ai
apporté ma un spectre radio m du doux
nom de gety qui est avec moi pour
caractériser donc la lumière ambiante et
qui me rendait un spectre de cette
lumière c'est à dire la répartition en
intensité de la lumière aux différentes
longueurs d'onde donc on voit sur
l'interface du logiciel l'arc en ciel du
visible avec à gauche l'ultraviolet dont
je vous parlais à droite tout à l'heure
et à droite l'infrarouge légalement et
donc en fait ces données là ils varient
énormément selon l'heure du jour ou le
lieu où vous êtes donc l'altitude et
puis il y aussi beaucoup la météo
donc en un mois de terrain j'ai une
collection absolument effrayante de
donner à prêter parce que oui
sur cette photo du terrain j'avais l'air
contente mais souvent je peux vous dire
qu'on en a bavé vraiment quoi que ce
soit pour grimper aux arbres ou parfois
régler un gros diamètre dans un
laboratoire de mesure
ils butent souvent je me suis un peu
demandées
bah oui ce que je faisais là et pourquoi
on faisait tous ça peut-être que vous
pendant cet exposé vous êtes un peu posé
la question aussi va faire tout ça c'est
faire de la recherche fondamentale ça
sert à comprendre les équilibres du
vivant qui est autour de nous c'est un
but en soi
bien sûr et ensuite de façon plus
appliquer ça peut permettre de servir de
base à la bure inspiration donc c'est
toutes ces innovations qui se reposent
sur des exemples d'adaptation à
l'environnement qui sont donc triés sur
le volet par des millénaires de
sélection naturelle
peut-être qu'un jour qui sait on créera
des surfaces anti reflets
autonettoyantes et grâce à ses ailes de
papillon moi je dois dire
personnellement ce qui me touche là
dedans c'est que le point de départ de
tous amassé des scientifiques qui se
sont baladés à la forêt qui se sont
accroupis dans l'est souvent dû regarder
ces papillons en se posant des questions
là-dessus alors peut-être que vous
n'êtes ni physicien ni manteau logique
c'est vous n'aurait sûrement pas un
microscope électronique à balayage dans
votre sac pendant votre prochaine balade
en forêt mais si jamais vous croisiez en
papillon ce jour la barre pensez un peu
à ce petit exposé je vous assure qu avec
un peu de patience et votre curiosité
vous n'aurez pas besoin d'autre chose
vous profitez d'un voyage unique aussi
lumineux que poétique sur les milliers
des cayes de ces papillons transparent
[Applaudissements]